[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las
principales noticias las más destacadas
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 soy santiago lópez gonzález a
continuación les presento el sumario de
temas que trataremos en esta edición
avanza el desarrollo de una posible
vacuna contra el cob y 19 hubo avances y
anuncios importantes a lo largo de esta
semana en cuanto a las diferentes
investigaciones muchas de ellas ya están
haciendo pruebas en humanos conversamos
precisamente con una persona que se
postuló como voluntario para que la
vacuna en desarrollo de oxford y
astrazéneca sea testeado en su cuerpo ya
nos contará la historia pero ya también
registró más de 29 mil personas
fallecidas por cuenta de la pandemia y
de acuerdo a su número de población
presenta la tasa de mortalidad más alta
del mundo el virus ha llevado a este
país a ser el quinto a nivel mundial en
el número de casos y el segundo en
américa latina' vamos a analizar la
situación con nuestro corresponsal en la
ciudad de lima y argentina también
prolongó el confinamiento debido al
aumento de los casos a lo largo de esta
semana en un período de 24 horas allí
fueron confirmados 12 mil nuevos casos
el gobierno tomó medidas como revertir
la decisión de abrir los restaurantes y
los cafés pero en buenos aires y fueron
abiertos a partir
el lunes de esta semana esto mientras la
economía sigue padeciendo veremos cuál
es el panorama y la situación que está
viviendo argentina de cara a hacer
frente a esta pandemia
pero vamos directo a la información esta
semana fueron registradas como lo
decíamos varias noticias en cuanto al
estudio y también al desarrollo de la
vacuna contra el kobe 19 la revista
médica the lancet publicó los primeros
resultados positivos de los ensayos
clínicos de la vacuna sputnik fiat
significa sputnik 5 según la publicación
de tras 42 días de seguimiento el
componente presenta un muy buen perfil
de seguridad sin eventos adversos las
compañías han office y glaxo smith line
también indicaron que han comenzado a
probar en humanos una posible vacuna
contra el joven 19 440 personas hacen
parte de este estudio que también se une
al avance que tiene la dupla oxford
astrazéneca que ya viene haciendo la
fase de testeo en humanos
muchos voluntarios han escrito en este
tipo de programas para ayudar al estudio
y al desarrollo de este antídoto que nos
puede ayudar a hacer frente al korona
virus del cobi 19 pablo andrés berra es
ciudadano argentino es voluntario para
la prueba de la vacuna contra el
coronavirus experimental que está siendo
desarrollada como ya lo decía por oxford
astrazéneca no se atiende a esta hora
desde la ciudad de johannesburgo en
sudáfrica muy buenas noches pablo allí
en la ciudad de johannesburgo en
sudáfrica y quiero comenzar por
preguntarle porque ha sido ser
voluntario para este tipo de
experimentos que muchas personas piensan
que puede llegar a ser muy riesgoso para
la salud
no supongo que no es tan riesgoso no yo
siempre considerado quienes están atrás
de esta vacuna de oxford que es el
gobierno de inglaterra eeuu el
laboratorio la universidad de bits de
acá de sudáfrica que bastante tiene su
prestigio es la universidad de oxford el
laboratorio como decía así que nunca he
tenido miedo a ofrecerme como voluntario
se sabe que para salir de esta pandemia
hay una sola sabe que es la vacuna no
hay para llegar a la vacuna se necesitan
los voluntarios así que este buenas
buenas formas de dar un granito de arena
no para que salgamos de esto lo más
pronto posible pablo como fueron las
condiciones que prometió el laboratorio
la universidad allí en sudáfrica que ha
sido el puente con ustedes los
voluntarios para llevar a cabo esta
digamos negociación porque aquí tiene
que haber unos puntos de acuerdo entre
las personas que están siendo
voluntarias y los que están estudiando
este posible antídoto
no hay ningún tipo de beneficio para el
voluntario solamente esto de apoyar a
salir de esta pandemia no no no tenemos
ninguna remuneración siempre es han sido
bastante abiertos y francos en cuanto a
lo que podría llegar a pasar al ser
voluntarios este bueno afortunadamente
este nunca nada pasado malos siempre nos
dijeron que nada debería pasar en cuanto
a los efectos secundarios
por recibir la vacuna solamente estos
mínimos efectos que uno tiene como
cualquier persona tiene al recibir otro
tipo de vacuna no un poquito de dolor de
cabeza fiebre pero no más que eso si
pablo cuando comenté con algunos de mis
colegas que lo iba a entrevistar en este
programa muchos me preguntaban y cómo
fue el procedimiento cómo fue ese día
ese momento en el que usted fue para
hacerse la inoculación y ya empezar a
ser parte de este estudio
si acá buscaban 2020 voluntarios un
grupo que tengan vih otros grupos de
voluntarios que no estén en un grupo de
riesgo de gente de 18 a 65 años que no
tenían hipertensión diabetes esta
obesidad bueno varios requisitos bueno
pasó todos estos requisitos como me
llamó para decirme que recibía la
primera dosis de un principio la vacuna
de ojos era una sola dosis con el tiempo
ellos se dieron cuenta de que con una
dosis no alcanzaba el 100 por ciento
tener anticuerpos solamente el 91 por
ciento así que deciden por eso me llaman
un par de semanas después de la primera
dosis dar una segunda dosis a todos los
voluntarios no solamente aquí en
sudáfrica sino también en inglaterra en
los lugares pero así en el lugar
testigos por está experimentando y bueno
un mes después de la primera dosis nos
aplicaron la segunda y última éste
nos dijeron que el 100 por ciento de los
que hemos recibido la vacuna sabemos
generado los anticuerpos necesarios y
las células de memoria que nadie ha
tenido ningún problema de complicado de
salud hace cuánto hace cuánto fue la
inoculación y ya nos estaba comentando
en la respuesta anterior sobre algunos
de los efectos un dolor de cabeza de
pronto fiebre ellos y qué indicaciones
le dieron qué síntomas podría presentar
o qué problemas podría empezar a
presentar y que debían ser importantes
para tomar en cuenta y anunciarles y
darles a ellos la información necesaria
que que para este procedimiento
si eso nos dijeron que el peor de los
escenarios que alguien pudiera llegar a
tener una reacción alérgica no a la
vacuna que eso podría ser bastante malo
pero bueno hubo un par de semanas
estudios de estudios previos en todos
los voluntarios para ver que nadie
tuviera que pasar por ese momento osea
estudios de sangre de orina varias cosas
como para ver si no hay posibles
reacciones alérgicas este no ha habido
casos nos dijeron las doctoras que
experimentan aquí en sudáfrica tenemos
ahora un seguimiento de 12 meses todos
los lunes voy al laboratorio me sacan
sangre y hacen hisopado y bueno me van
comentando que como son los resultados
de los estudios previos
-pablo cuánto dura todo este proceso
después de que pasen estos efectos en su
cuerpo por cuánto tiempo más va a tener
que estar en contacto con estas
autoridades en torno a lo que suceda con
su cuerpo después de la inoculación
bueno por un lado estamos en las 24
horas en contacto con a través de una
aplicación del teléfono móvil y por otro
lado estas visitas semanales al
laboratorio con los que ellos quieren
saber ellos ya saben que la vacuna
funciona que el 100% de los penados
tienen los anticuerpos pero que lo que
no se sabe todavía aún es cuánto tiempo
permanecen los anticuerpos en la gente
vacunada se sabe que hay por lo menos 6
meses pero no cuánto se hace sabemos que
la vacuna va a ser aprobada mucho tiempo
antes de estos 12 meses que tenemos que
nosotros los voluntarios este hacer este
proceso de seguimiento con oxford pero
bueno esos 23 meses para saber
determinar bien cuánto es el tiempo que
el cuerpo y los anticuerpos permanecen
en el cuerpo no pablo en caso que usted
presente algún síntoma o alguna
complicación que va a requerir
asistencia médica hospitalización que su
cuerpo empiece a reaccionar de una
manera adversa
ha dicho el laboratorio de la
universidad que puede garantizarle a
usted dado este escenario ya sabemos que
los efectos secundarios han sido menores
simplemente un dolor de cabeza o fiebre
pero si su cuerpo reacciona de una
manera diferente si usted empresa está
presenta complicaciones
dos semanas antes de la primera dosis
hemos leído un montón de documentos el
laboratorio ha firmado documentos
diciendo que si llegara a pasar algo a
ellos obviamente cubre el 100% de los
gastos de internación o cualquier cosa
que pudiera pasar eso nos garantizaron y
bueno nos han firmado los documentos
para que nos garantizan que ellos
estarían cubriendo todos los gastos
necesarios
pablo muchas gracias por compartir con
nosotros su experiencia su aporte al
desarrollo de esta vacuna a nivel
internacional el mundo entero está
pendiente del desarrollo de esta vacuna
de alguna de las que se está
desarrollando para poder superar esta
pandemia muchas gracias por haber
compartido su historia con nosotros aquí
en france 24
hasta pronto las veces vamos a avanzar
con otros temas de la agenda un informe
de amnistía internacional señaló que
méxico acumula el mayor número de
trabajadores de la salud que han
fallecido por causa de la pandemia la
cifra ronda los 1.320 porque qué es lo
que está sucediendo los detalles en el
siguiente informe
los profesionales de la salud mexicanos
son los más afectados por la pandemia de
coronavirus hasta 1.320 trabajadores han
perdido la vida en su lucha contra el
virus de los más de 97 mil 600
contagiados estos son los datos más
altos del mundo que superan a los de
países como eeuu o brasil en méxico el
número oficial de muertes de personas
trabajadoras de la salud ha llegado a
las cifras sobrecogedora de 1.320
personas el 25 de agosto del ministerio
de salud de méxico confirmó 97 mil 632
casos de kobe 19 entre las personas
trabajadores de la salud la causa los
constantes brotes en centros médicos
registrados por la falta de equipos
protectores incluso medio año después
del primer caso registrado esto se
siente especialmente en las provincias
pero estos no son los únicos datos
negativos que registra el país su tasa
de mortalidad con respecto a los
contagios es con diferencia la más alta
del mundo con 10,8 por ciento
prácticamente dobla a las cifras de
otros países como irán perú bolivia o
indonesia algo que desde el gobierno
justifican con la condición física de
los mexicanos pero
se puede deber a la falta de pruebas
y datos en méxico es que las principales
comorbilidades que generan enfermedad
grave y por lo tanto defunciones en kobe
de 19 al menos son estos 3 sobrepeso y
obesidad diabetes e hipertensión y eso
es algo que es una prevalencia alta en
la población mexicana y por lo tanto
también contribuye definitivamente los
resultados que hemos visto a pesar de
los datos méxico está en pleno
desconocimiento desde hace meses un
movimiento que busca reactivar la
maltrecha economía pero que según las
cifras ha acelerado la pandemia
y colombia completó su primera semana de
reactivación económica y social con
restricciones el aeropuerto
internacional que es fundamental para la
interconexión regional en colombia fue
puesto nuevamente en marcha la apertura
del aeropuerto internacional eldorado
abre ya una puerta de esperanza para la
economía del país
colombia vuelve poco a poco a su ritmo
cotidiano con el decreto 1178 del 25 de
agosto el gobierno de dictó varias
medidas que rigen en el país a partir
del primero de septiembre en vez de
seguir en un aislamiento obligatorio
preventivo se pasa a una fase de
aislamiento selectivo es decir sólo los
que tengan síntomas de kobe 19 no podrán
salir a la calle habrá libre circulación
y movilización en todo el territorio
pero los colombianos tendrán que seguir
con los cuidados como el uso de vido de
mascarilla y el distanciamiento social
el aeropuerto internacional eldorado
retomado operaciones sólo para algunos
vuelos nacionales y la terminal de buses
también abrió de nuevo sus puertas más
que por placer muchas personas viajan
por necesidad un motivo medio que tengo
que cuidar a mi mamá
una anciana
bueno me tocaba cuidarla desde antes
pero como me agarra la cuarentena aquí
no pude viajar antes estoy como ahora
están abriendo ahora que puedo viajar
el transporte masivo pasará de operar
del 35 al 50 por ciento de aforo el
comercio no esencial funcionará con un
sistema de alternancia por ahora
escuelas y universidades mantendrán las
clases virtuales y su apertura dependerá
del avance del virus respiratorio para
algunos trabajadores informales la
ausencia de estudiantes los perjudica yo
un día normal a veces por ahí cincuenta
mil pesitos se ganaba uno diarios
crítica neumática prácticamente de diez
mil diez
por lo solo que está en nosotros como le
comenta no dependemos exclusivamente los
estudiantes bares discotecas piscinas
iglesias casinos y lugares de grandes
espectáculos no podrán funcionar por
ahora por su parte los restaurantes
comenzarán a operar bajo el programa
bogotá a cielo abierto con mesas al aire
libre y como la mayoría de los países
del mundo perú también ha visto como su
economía cae debido a la pandemia del
país suramericano presenta una
contracción trimestral del 30 por ciento
de su producto interno bruto hay
desempleo al cierre de empresas ya esto
se suma la tasa de mortalidad más alta
del mundo también ser el quinto país con
la mayor cantidad de casos de contagio
de kobe 19 este es el panorama
a marta morales la invade en los
recuerdos las pérdidas y las deudas
contraídas debido al confinamiento su
restaurante quebró y 19 familias se
quedaron sin sustento económico tener la
continuidad de un restaurante abierto
pues fue bastante trabajo lo que se hizo
es que luchó y se mantuvo pero ahorita
así graves graves nos vemos así como
martha muchos empresarios tuvieron que
cerrar sus negocios pero se encuentra
oficialmente en recesión en el segundo
trimestre del año su producto bruto
interno se redujo en 30.2 por ciento
como consecuencia de la estricta
cuarentena impuesta para contener la
pandemia del cob y 19 las autoridades
han reconocido que el duro retroceso
para que este 2020 su economía tenga una
caída del 12% estamos en una recesión y
con peligro de que se convierta en una
depresión que nos quedemos mucho tiempo
sin poder volver a crecer
normales no
esto porque hay un entrampamiento la
economía peruana casi 7 millones de
peruanos perdieron sus empleos los
expertos consideran que esto generará
más informalidad en el trabajo y mayor
pobreza los ciudadanos vislumbra un
futuro incierto están quebrando el
personal está siendo despedido los
hogares están en una situación económica
muy triste no hay para los alimentos de
la familia pero ser un comerciante
independiente
simplemente me quedé en la calle viejo
todo mi capital me lo tengo que comer
porque no tiene trabajo no podía salir a
vender no puede hacer nada simplemente
me quedé en mi casa encerrado tres meses
para mí fue una decisión acertada de la
cuarentena ahora que no sé si eso hay
que aceptarlo no se hizo bien muchas
cosas no por ejemplo el tema de la de
los bonos
marta ha decidido reinventarse como
consultora de belleza en la otra cara de
un perú que no se rinde ante la
adversidad
y vamos a ampliar información sobre lo
que está pasando en perú con francisco
sacarían nuestro corresponsal de france
24 en lima la capital peruana muy buenas
noches francisco y porque las cifras no
retroceden porque siguen los contagios
las muertes siguen incrementándose
mientras muchos países de la región
parece que comienzan a tener un respiro
frente a la pandemia
buena noches santiago más de 670.000
casos positivos y más de 29.000
fallecidos según cifras oficiales son el
fiel reflejo de lo que algunos expertos
señalan como las causas principales del
problema se critica lo que ellos
mencionan como una la falta de una
estrategia integral de atención de la
pandemia por parte del gobierno peruano
otro elemento importante señalan que
existe un fenómeno cultural que es que a
muchos peruanos les cuesta les resulta
difícil guardar un distanciamiento
social se producen aglomeraciones en los
mercados en el transporte público en las
colas de la fila de los bancos para
cobrar los bonos se señala también que
no hay cuarentena que sea efectiva o
mejor dicho protocolos sanitarios que
puedan surtir efecto si existen más de
un 70% de los peruanos que tiene empleo
informal y ellos tienen que salir a
trabajar día a día para llevar sustento
económico a sus viviendas hay otro
parque otra parte de la población que no
tiene refrigeradora y si o si tienen que
salir
a diario a hacer compras en los mercados
hoy también se reportan de acuerdo a las
autoridades que hay contagio en las
denominadas fiestas como bits son
fiestas clandestinas que muchos peruanos
a pesar del toque de queda se reúnen y
también existen contagios en el interior
de las viviendas a pesar que el gobierno
del presidente de martín vizcarra ha
sido muy enfático en prohibir las
reuniones familiares y sociales la alta
tasa de contagios continúa a esto hay
que añadir francisco la mala red
hospitalaria que tiene este país que
tomó por sorpresa a las autoridades de
cara a esta pandemia hay una fecha
importante francisco y es el 8 de
septiembre comienzan las pruebas de una
de las vacunas chinas allí en en perú
que expectativa hay
hay mucha expectativa con decirle
santiago que se dio el inicio a las
inscripciones este domingo que pasó en
tan sólo una hora se cubrieron los 6000
cupos y es así que es este 8 de
septiembre sino fire de china va a
iniciar los ensayos con 6.000
voluntarios peruanos esto va a ser
estudiado por dos universidades locales
seguidamente a mediados de septiembre el
laboratorio janssen de la norteamericana
johnson y johnson va a ser sus testigos
posteriormente la alemana de curva que
continuará con las pruebas de esta
vacuna
finalmente astrazéneca junto a la
universidad de oxford inglaterra va a
continuar esto ha generado mucha
expectativa y según como señalan algunos
especialistas estas pruebas va a ser de
beneficio a perú porque al haber en el
país probado esta eficacia pero va a
tener posibilidades de tener un acceso a
las vacunas tan pronto éstas sean
probadas porque se probaron su
eficiencia en territorio peruano
francisco y cómo hacer este
procedimiento van a ser solamente
estudiadas con algunos habitantes
voluntarios de lima o se van a hacer
pruebas también en otros departamentos
peruanos quienes pueden participar cómo
ha sido el procedimiento
justamente tres laboratorios van a
iniciar las pruebas en lima pero hay
este laboratorio astrazéneca junto con
la universidad de oxford ellos han
solicitado que les permitan hacer los
ensayos clínicos tanto en la franja
costera de perú como en la amazonía para
ver otro tipo de situación geográfica y
las reacciones de las personas para
estos ensayos clínicos las autoridades
peruanas han establecido que participen
ciudadanos mayores de 18 años de edad en
condición de salud favorable y se
destaca que también incluso pueden
participar mientras tengan un cuadro
estable personas que sean padezcan la
enfermedad de diabetes o inclusive del
vih siempre y cuando esto esté estable
el gobierno peruano ha programado que
los voluntarios puedan acceder a un
seguro de más de medio millón de dólares
en la eventualidad que se produjera
un caso de reacción adversa francisco
muchas gracias por este reporte sobre el
panorama que está viviendo perú en torno
a la pandemia hablamos ahora de brasil
este país superó los 4 millones de casos
confirmados según lo dice el conteo de
la universidad johns hopkins
localmente las autoridades también
anunciaron que el número de víctimas se
ubicó por debajo de 1000 por primera vez
en muchos meses estas cifras son vistas
con recelo por parte de los expertos y
de la comunidad médica brasileña porque
lo explicamos en el siguiente reportaje
el hobbit 19 se mueve con volatilidad en
brasil aunque el país es de lejos el más
afectado por la pandemia en américa
latina' investigadores del imperial
college de londres calcularon que la
tasa de transmisión del virus en agosto
fue menor a 1 el nivel necesario para
controlar el virus esta información se
dio a conocer justo cuando el país cerró
una semana la baja en el número de
fallecidos
la semana pasada por primera vez el
promedio de muertes fue de menos de 1000
por un día una estadística celebrada por
políticos cuya estrategia es promover
una mayor flexibilidad en lo económico y
lo social
y sociales pero aunque estos datos han
sido interpretados por el gobierno como
una señal para la reapertura económica
que ya se ha venido reactivando en el
país en los últimos días las cifras
repuntaron y los expertos advierten que
es demasiado pronto para pensar que lo
peor ya pasó
es un momento muy delicado para nuestro
país y de mucha preocupación para la
cruz roja porque tenemos que hacerle
entender al gobierno que la economía y
la salud es importante las personas que
están trabajando se están contagiando en
todas pero la narrativa del presidente
jair bolsonaro de desvirtuar la pandemia
parece ir ganando terreno la vida
nocturna y los días de playa volvieron a
llenar las calles de las principales
ciudades brasileñas
en brasil todo está desorganizado si
esto continúa todo será peor
varios expertos coinciden en que si se
hubieran tomado medidas a tiempo para si
él no habría tenido que llorar tantas
víctimas y todo parece indicar que la
cuenta no va a parar
y argentina mantiene su cuarentena los
casos de kobe 19 en este país están
disparados esta semana en un periodo de
24 horas fueron registrados 12.000
nuevos contagios esto ha llevado a que
el gobierno federal y también algunas
provincias hayan tenido que tomar
medidas adicionales vamos a conocer cuál
es el panorama con natalio cost hoy
desde la ciudad de buenos aires- nuestro
corresponsal de france 24
natalio van cinco meses de cuarentena en
argentina prácticamente ese ya estamos
por cerrar este quinto mes ha sido una
de las cuarentenas más largas del mundo
porque siguen los números
incrementándose es un escenario similar
al de pero también
bueno santiago unas noches yo creo que
la clave está en lo que acabas de decir
en que la cuarentena es muy larga y
entonces hay una suerte de cansancio y
agotamiento en la población que lleva a
muchos a empezar a salir por un lado por
necesidad seguramente a trabajar pero
también muchos otros por cansancio a
hacer una vida social que tal vez no es
la recomendada por los especialistas
además también los especialistas señalan
algo curioso que muchas personas con
síntomas leves a pesar de que hay
disponibilidades de pruebas para
cristianos no se están yendo a testear y
eso hace difícil la tarea de
identificación de los posibles focos de
coronavirus y salud que por ejemplo nos
comentaba él javier farina que es el
médico infectólogo que es miembro de la
sociedad argentina de infectología y de
la sociedad argentina de terapia
intensiva hablando durante el día de hoy
en una entrevista colectiva con
corresponsables extranjeros acerca de
esta situación y él nos decía algo muy
importante que tenía que ver con que
puede llegar a ocurrir en los próximos
días y semanas si los niveles de
contagio siguen tan altos como hasta
ahora donde estamos teniendo días
con 10.000 casos reportados e incluso
más de 10.000 como decías vos en la
introducción al principio en torno a
12.000 en uno de los últimos reportes
que fue la mañana de hoy escuchamos lo
que decía javier farina en esta
entrevista colectivo
si nosotros seguimos con más de 10.000
casos diarios por más de por más de dos
semanas pero más y seguimos con más de
1000 casos diarios por más de dos
semanas hay altas chance de saturación
es de más después hay que ver donde éste
tenía porque argentina a diferencia de
europa es muy regionalizado y hay
ciudades que están muy lejos de obra
entonces que en un momento estos casos
en el amba se calmen y el sistema no
sostiene y esto se distribuye por otras
ciudades del interior es una cosa si
todo se empieza se empieza a concentrar
en los lugares donde se concentre van a
saturar el sistema
natalio hoy bueno a lo largo de esta
semana en la ciudad de buenos aires ya
permitieron abrir los restaurantes y
algunos cafés una medida que ha sido un
poco controvertida allí en la capital
argentina como ha avanzado esta medida
bueno quiero hacer una aclaración javier
farina mencionó el amba justamente el
amba es el área metropolitana de buenos
aires que incluye a la ciudad de buenos
aires y el conurbano que la rodea el
conurbano no permitió esta apertura a la
ciudad buenos aires si es solo en
exterior con mesas separadas con cierta
distancia no más de 4 personas por mes a
los primeros días el tiempo no acompañó
fue muy lluvioso entonces no se pudo
medir bien pero en estos días está
mejorando el tiempo comienza el fin de
semana y va a ser la gran prueba de
fuego de hecho por el aumento de casos
que están viendo en estos días no se
descarta para nada que se pueda llegar a
dar marcha atrás con esta medida aquí en
la ciudad de buenos aires para tratar de
detener el incremento de los contagios y
en este incremento de los contagios
es importante la red hospitalaria cómo
está la ocupación de las salas de
cuenten sigo en argentina
pone algo muy importante todos los
expertos señalan que la cuarentena
temprana permitió reforzar el sistema de
salud reforzar las salas de terapia
inters intensiva hasta cierto punto por
supuesto porque es muy difícil luego
equiparlas con los profesionales
necesarios más allá de los equipos
técnicos y las camas ahora según los
datos oficiales dependiendo de las zonas
del país puede estar entre 60 70 y 80 la
ocupación pero lo que dicen en la
sociedad argentina de terapia intensiva
es que puede llegar a ser más alto
especialmente en los centros
hospitalarios y de atención más grandes
donde se concentra la mayor demanda así
que aunque hasta ahora no está saturado
en casi ningún lugar del país a
excepción por ejemplo del norte en la
provincia de jujuy donde ya hay reportes
de que tienen que elegir a qué pacientes
dejan de ocupar una cama de terapia
intensiva y respirador ya cuáles no lo
cual es gravísimo en general en la
mayoría del país todavía no han llegado
ese punto de saturación pero hay miedo
como escuchamos antes de que se pueda
llegar en las próximas semanas es el
temor de todas las autoridades natalio
llegar a
una saturación de los sistemas
hospitalarios muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de buenos aires
vamos a ir ahora a nuestra sección en
redes veamos otras noticias destacadas
de esta semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana
en américa la vacuna rusa sputnik biato
sputnik 5 no presenta efectos adversos y
tiene una respuesta inmunitaria
aceptable así lo ha dado a conocer la
revista médica lancet que dio a conocer
precisamente los primeros resultados de
las fases 1 y 2 de esta vacuna
según la publicación la vacuna es
completamente segura genera anticuerpos
pero no muestra resultados en personas
que sean mayores de 65 años y necesita
dos inyecciones
es decir inducción y un refuerzo que
tiene dos vectores de virus que causan
el resfriado común la gripe común su
desarrollo pues todavía está en marcha y
su estudio por supuesto también esta
semana también lado ms indicó que pese a
los importantes avances que están
teniendo las diferentes vacunas no
espera que haya vacunaciones masivas
contra el kobe 19 hasta
del año 2021 esto mientras aumenta la
presión y también la ansiedad a nivel
internacional por desarrollar una vacuna
experimental que permita revertir las
cifras que están presentando los países
ya son más de 26.4 millones de personas
contagiadas en el mundo y hay una
carrera contra el tiempo por desarrollar
este antídoto nos vamos ahora hasta
canadá allí los expertos de salud
indicaron que para evitar una doble
epidemia es decir una epidemia de gripe
estacional más la de kobe 19 es más
importante que nunca vacunarse contra la
gripa estacional o la influenza esto de
cara a que ya está llegando el otoño y
el frío allí en canadá entre más
defensas y mejor armado esté su cuerpo
pues será menos vulnerable a contraer
otros virus que pueden abrir la puerta
para que llegue el coronavirus del joven
19 y también en canadá seguimos en este
país porque hay temor allí por parte de
las autoridades debido al aumento de los
casos de kobe 19 el repunte de personas
contagiadas y el incremento de las
cifras se están registrando
algunas cifras similares a los contagios
que se estaban viviendo a mediados de
año cuando fue el pico de contagio en
canadá la mayoría de las provincias
están en alerta pero sobre todo ontario
québec alberta y columbia británica son
las provincias donde se están
presentando el mayor número de personas
contagiadas canadá contabiliza hasta el
momento 132 mil casos confirmados y
nueve mil cien personas han perdido la
vida hasta el momento
hablamos ahora de colombia o nuevamente
de colombia allí también fue autorizada
la apertura de los restaurantes los
establecimientos podrán atender a sus
clientes con estrictas medidas
respetando protocolos de seguridad y
muchos de ellos con las mesas fuera de
los locales en áreas abiertas veamos
esta es una imagen que no se veía desde
marzo cuando inició el confinamiento los
restaurantes pueden de nuevo recibir
clientes este grupo de amigos no tardó
en regresar a este lugar una forma de
apoyar a uno de los sectores más
golpeados por la crisis
vivo la oportunidad de hacer un apoyo
precisamente al sector y preferimos hoy
no cocinar desde el hogar si no salimos
a poder respirar aire puro y estar en
tema y un esparcimiento social y creo
que estos sectores por parte del estado
y por parte de la sociedad se deben
impulsar porque hay muchos
en manos de obras calificadas que están
impactando sus hogares para este
restaurante la autorización dada por el
gobierno colombiano y la alcaldía de
bogotá es un alivio después de más de
cinco meses de limitación es muy alegre
todo por por la reapertura porque ya de
a poco vamos vamos mejorando el proceso
con la cav a mejorar las ventas va a
mejorar todo para la compañía y para
nuestros compañeros que en algún momento
tuvieron que quedarse en casa sin
trabajo pero en esta exclusiva es una
gastronómica de la capital colombiana
muchos restaurantes no pudieron superar
el confinamiento y tuvieron que entregar
sus locales la situación sigue siendo
difícil en toda la ciudad en este barrio
popular pocos pares abrieron sus puertas
a los clientes antes de la pandemia este
comedor que recibía un promedio de 400
clientes al día hoy sirvió a que en las
40 el problema ahora que es la cuestión
económica no la dificultad de plata del
del
de la gente humilde pues promedio de
clase media baja vez que la que la que
gasta en la plática pues es lo que pasa
que vuelva a haber a superarse esta
dificultad económica para que la gente
tenga capacidad de compra y de pago los
restaurantes de bogotá están autorizados
a recibir clientes solamente de jueves a
domingo con máximo el 25 por ciento del
aforo
y este fue nuestro resumen semanal en
kobe 19 la semana en américa nos
volvemos a encontrar la próxima semana
por favor dejen todos sus mensajes y sus
comentarios preguntas también a través
de las redes sociales de france 24 y a
mi cuenta personal arroba sant y luego
nosotros nos volvemos a encontrar la
próxima semana hasta entonces
[Música]